[موسيقى]
على امتداد دول الساحل الافريقيه وجنوب
الصحراء وحتى في شمال افريقيا بنيت فرنسا
في الاونه الاخيره بالكثير من الارتكاسات
ومن فكت مشاعر العداد ضد سياساتها
وقياداتها تتاجج كما تظهر بوضوح حلفتات
والشعارات والاعلام الروسيه التي رفعها
المتظاهرون في باماكو ونيامي وغيرها من
العواصم الافريقيه ورغم ان الرئيس حاول
اعاده ضبط وترتيب سياسات بلاده تجاه دول
القاره السمراء وحاول كذلك تاسيس شراكات
جديده قائمه على الاحترام المتبادل الا ان
نفود فرنسا التقليدي بات مع ذلك يتقلص
ويواجه العديد من التحديات والصعوبات فما
هي اسباب هذا الانتكاسات المتتاليه
للمصالح الفرنسيه في مناطق نفوذها
التقليديه في افريقيا وما هي الاوراق التي
ما زالت بحوزه باريس للحفاظ على ما تبقى
لها من نفوذ وقواعد عسكريه ومواجهه الجدد
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم بوتيره متسارعه تتراجع مكانه
فرنسا في عموم افريقيا وبشكل خاص في منطقه
الساحل الافريقي ولم تكن النيجر سوى قطعه
اخرى من قطعه الاقليميه التي باتت خارج
دائره النفود الفرنسيه
للوقوف على اسباب هذه الانتكاسات
المتزايده لفرنسا في مناطق نفوذها
التقليدي وفشل محاوله اعاده ضبط علاقاتها
الصعبه المثقل بالارث الاستعماريه الذي
استغله خصومه كذلك ولا سيما الروس ومستقبل
الصراع على النفوس في القاره الافريقيه
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه من
باريس
في المعهد الفرنسي للتحليل الاستراتيجي من
الرباط الدكتور تاج الدين الحسيني استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه محمد الخامس
ونامل ان يلتحق بنا من جمله الدكتور احمد
جده محمد البشير استاذ الاستاذ الجامعي
وعضو البرلمان الانتقالي في تشاد وهو ايضا
وزير ساب ق تقلد مناصب وزاريه من بينها
وزاره التعليم فاهلا بهم جميعا
بعد فتره وجيزه من انتخابه عام 2017 اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي المكرم في خطاب القاه في
وجادوجو انه يريد القطيعه مع سياسه فرنسا
الافريقيه التي ظلت على مدى عقود طويله هي
السمه الرئيسيه للعلاقات بين فرنسا
ومستعمراتها السابقه في القاره السمراء
وفي عام 2020 قال لمجله جون فريك بين
فرنسا وافريقيا يجب ان تكون قصه حب غير ان
قصه الحب هذه لم يكتب لها النجاح بل على
العكس من ذلك تنامت المشاعر المعاديه
لفرنسا في العديد من البلدان الافريقيه
على المستويين الحكومي والشعبي يثير
تساؤلات حول الاخطاء التي ارتكبتها فرنسا
وتدفع ثمنها اليوم
في اواخر ولايته الرئاسيه الاولى سن
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بدعه لم
يسبقوا اليها احد من الرؤساء السابقين فقد
دعى الى النسخه الثامنه والعشرين من القمه
الفرنسيه الافريقيه شبابا افارقه ورواد
اعمال وفنانين ورياضيين ولم يدعوا اليها
احدا من القاده والسياسيين سعى كروم من
خلال ذلك للتواصل مع فعاليات المجتمع
المدني الافريقي في دول
الفرنسي عقودا لكن مشاعر مقاومه ذاك
النفوذ كانت تتنامى بشكل لافت وبسرعه تتسع
رقعتها في ولايته الرئاسيه الثانيه وقبيل
زيارته اربع دول في المنطقه اعلن ماكرون
استراتيجيه فرنسيه جديده في افريقيا
غدا سيشهد حضورنا في القواعد العسكريه
تاسيس مدارس واكاديميات يسيرها الموظفون
الفرنسيون الباقون هناك
وموظفون افارقه كما يرغب بذلك شركائنا
الافارقه وبشروطهم ووفق المحادثات التي
اجريتها مع شركائنا فسيبدا هذا التحول
خلال الاشهر المقبله مع تقليص واضح
لتعدادنا
وعد ماكرون بتحويل النفوذ الفرنسيه في
افريقيا الى شراكه تدار فيها القواعد
العسكريه بشكل مشترك مع الجيوش المحليه
لكن اغراءاته لم تمحو الصوره النمطيه
لفرنسا في الوجدان الافريقي ولم تهدئ
الثوره على باريس في شوارع عده دول في
منطقه الساحل والصحراء فبعد مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وغينيا كوناكري جاء الدور على النيجر
التي مثلت الحاضنه الاخيره وربما الاهم
للوجود الفرنسي عسكريا واقتصاديا
تماما مثل باماكو ووجدوجو غداه الانقلاب
فيهما رفعت في مظاهرتها لافتات وشعارات
معاديه لفرنسا ومرحبه بروسيا التي ما فتات
تنازع باريس مكانتها ونفوذها في افريقيا
رسمت هذه الاحداث المتتاليه ملامح حقبه
جديده تصدرتها نخب عسكريه افريقيه نزاعه
لتنويع الشراكات والخروج من تحت العباءه
الفرنسيه
ما لم تغفل عنه باريس هو ان مشاعر العداء
ضدها لا تقتصر على دول منطقه الساحل
والصحراء ففي شمال افريقيا يطبع الفتور
علاقاتها مع الجزائر والمغرب اكبر بلدين
في المنطقه لم يبدي البلدان تاييدا للموقف
الفرنسي بشان انقلاب النيجر فقد حذرت
الجزائر من عواقب التدخل العسكري ان حدث
وتنهج الرباط ما تبدو سياسه دبلوماسيه
حذره تبقيها في منطقه حياد
امام هذا الواقع المحاصر للدوري الفرنسي
وقع 94 عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي رساله
مواجهه للرئيس ايمانويل ماكرو دعوا فيها
لاعاده النظر في سياسه فرنسا في افريقيا
التي تنتفض ضد ادوار باريس في المنطقه
ولفتوا الى انه يجري تبديل العلاقات
الفرنسيه الافريقيه بعلاقات مع روسيا على
المستوى العسكري وعلاقات مع الصين على
المستوى الاقتصادي وقال موقع والرساله ان
المظاهرات والاعمال المناهضه للفرنسيين
تمتد حتى الى البلدان الاقرب الى باريس
مثل السنغال وكوت ديفوار كما اشاروا الى
تراجع مستوى العلاقات مع الجزائر والمغرب
وتونس وهي دول قالوا انها تتجه نحو شركاء
جدد بعيدا عن باريس انها حاله ادراك في
الداخل الفرنسي لحتميه مراجعه جديده
منتظره من صانع القرار السياسي في باريس
لتلافي مزيد من التقهقر في افريقيا وانقاذ
المصالح الفرنسيه المتداعيه امام منافسه
نفوذ شرسه على القاره
وعلى الرغم من حقيقه ان الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون حول النائيه بنفسه عن الماضي
الاستعماري لبلاده فانه منذ بدايه رئاسته
ادلى بالعديد من التصريحات المثيره للجدل
بشان القاره الافريقيه ففي عامه الاول
مثلا في منصبه في قمه مجموعه العشرين في
يوليو تموز 2017 اشار مكرون الى ان التحدي
الذي تواجهه افريقيا حسب قوله حضاري وان
مشاكل التنميه فيها مرتبطه من بين امور
اخرى بارتفاع معدلات المواليد وان ذلك لن
يساعد في تحقيق الاستقرار
ولا تزال الذاكره الافريقيه تحتفظ كذلك
بتصريحات صادمه
لرؤساء فرنسيين اخرين من بينهم الرئيس
السابق نيكولازي الذي قال في خطاب له
القاعه عام 2007 في جامعه الشيخ في
العاصمه السنغاليه امام مجموعه من الطلاب
والمدرسين والسياسيين قال ان ماساه
افريقيا هي ان الرجل الافريقي لم يدخل
التاريخ بما فيه الكفايه ولم يندفع ابدا
نحو المستقبل
هذه تصريحات التي تعتبر مهينه وغيرها من
التصريحات ساهمت في تراجع صورتي ومكانه
فرنسا في افريقيا وهذا ما دعى المفكر
الكاميروني مبابي وهو احد ابرز المثقفين
الفرنكوفونيين في افريقيا الى القول ان
فرنسا لم تعد تمتلك الوسائل الضروريه
لتحقيق طموحاتها واضاف ان فرنسا توشك ان
تقع في واترلو فكريه وعسكريه وسياسيه
واقتصاديه اي في هزيمه كامله لن يسعى احد
بعدها بالتقرب منها وذلك في اشاره منه الى
معركه واترلو قرب بريكسال وهزيمه بونابرت
النهائيه امام الانجليز عام 1815
نرحب بانضمام ضيفنا من انجامينا الدكتور
احمد جده محمد البشير ونبدا بضيفنا من
باريس السيد بيير بارتلو نساله ما الذي ما
الذي اوصل فرنسا الى ما وصلت اليه في
علاقته مع افريقيا
هناك عوامل متعدده كما اشرتم
التصريحات هناك سلوك بالنسبه الى
الافريقيين لم يكن مناسبا هناك تصريحات
تركزي ولكن ايضا ماكرون الذي قال انه سوف
يغير في هذه التصريحات بالاضافه الى عناصر
اخرى لم يشر اليها في الصحافه الفرنسيه
مثالان مع بلدين البوركينا فاسو وعندما
مكروء زار البلاد منذ بضعه اشهر كان هناك
خطاب في الجامعه وكان هناك عدد من الطلاب
في بوركينا فاسو واراد ان يسلط الضوء على
العلاقه بين فرنسا والشباب وفي خلال هذا
التصريح كان يطلق الدعابات واطلق دعابه
اتجاه الرئيس وقال لربما ذهب لكي
مشغل الاضواء والمكيفات بسبب العطل اذا لا
يمكن ان يقوم الرئيس الفرنسي بالحديث بهذه
الطريقه على سبيل المثال لا يقوم بهذه
التصريحات مع اي رئيس اخر لا في الخليج
ولا في الصين ولا في اي بلد اخر ولكنه
بالفعل تقدم بهذه التصريحات مع بلد افريقي
ومؤخرا الكاميرون كذلك كان من بين البلدان
التي كانت تتاثر بفرنسا بشكل كبير ولكنه
لم ينحاز الى روسيا بشكل كبير هناك سفير
في فرنسا وهو مسؤول عن حمايه
الاقليات من مثليين الى اخره وذهب الى
كاميرون وقال ان هناك شخص
كاميروني يتعرض لمعامله سيئه لانه لم
يحترم حقه بالعيش حياه كريمه وهذه ليست
التقاليد في الكاميرون اذا عندما تسمح
فرنسا بهذه الامور مع بلدان اخرى هذا يؤدي
الى الرد الذي رايناه بعد 60 عاما من
الاستقلال عددا كبيرا من الدول الافريقيه
لا يزال تحت تاثير او نفوذ فرنسي على
المستوى الاقتصادي وعلى المستوى الامني
كذلك وبالتالي اعتقد انه لربما من
المبالغه ان نضع كل شيء على كاهل فرنسا
ولكن في الوقت نفسه كفرنسيا يجب ان نطرح
على انفسنا اسئله محدده هل نحن نقدم
التقدم والتنميه لهذه البلدان وهناك خصوم
مثل الصين وتركيا بلدان اخرى تقدم
المساعدات بشكل ملموس اكبر الى فرنسا اذا
نتحدث عن ركنين في سلوك فرنسا ادى الى هذه
الردود من الافريقيين هذه التصريحات
المسيئه لافريقيا وفرنسا يتعين عليها
مركزه على عدد من البلدان نتذكر ان هناك
عشرين بلد في افريقيا كانوا مستعمرين في
السابق من قبل الفرنسيين
وبالتالي يطرحوا السؤال بالنسبه الى
العلاقه مع هذه البلدان والعلاقه
الاقتصاديه مع فرنسا فرنسا هي السابع قوه
اقتصاديه في العالم وفي الماضي كانت القوه
الرابعه اذا لربما يجب على فرنسا ان تركز
على عدد من البلدان الاساسيه وتركز على
الاهداف لكي تسمح ان تحصل التنميه في هذه
البلدان نقاط عديده مهمه ولكن ربما اشرت
الى مساله مهمه جدا الى جانب التصريحات هي
موضوع ما يوصف به هنا نسال ضيفنا من زمن
الدكتور احمد جده دائما ما يلام على فرنسا
هو عقليه الاستعلاء والوصايه على الدول
الافريقيه تتعامل معهم من منط ق الدونيه
ولكن ايضا هناك مساله اقتصاديه اشار اليها
ضيفنا من باريس هناك تحكم فرنسي في
الموارد الطبيعيه وفي الاقتصاديات
الافريقيه هل هذه ايضا تلعب دورا مهما في
وصول فرنسا الى ما وصلت اليه الان
بطبيعه الحال
يعني ما ذكره الاخ الذي تداخل قبل قليل
طبعا اشار الى النقاط التي هي سبب يعني
عزوف الجيل جيل الشباب الافريقي عن فرنسا
طبعا المنظومه الاقتصاديه الفرنسيه كانت
مرتبطه ارتباط وثيق بالمنظومه السياسيه في
الدول الافريقيه بحيث ان الحكام الذين
تناوبوا على الحكم منذ الاستقلال كانوا
طبعا في المنظومه
الاساسيه بحيث فرنسا هي التي تحدد من
سيكون حاكم في هذه البلد واذا خرج عن عن
المالوف فهناك تنظيم انقلابات الى اخره
وهذا طبعا الجيل الحالي يعني بالذاكره
يعني يعرف ان يعني تدخل فرنسا يعني التحكم
فرنسا في السياسه واختيار الحكام وكذلك في
الاقتصاد طبعا يلعب دور كبير اضافه الى ان
المنظومه الاقتصاديه التي فرضتها في فرنسا
بعد الاستقلال او قبل الاستقلال عندما
اجبرت تقريبا الدول التي يعني كانت
مستعمره فرنسيه على اتفاقيه اقتصاديه تجعل
من العمله الفرنك سيفان الفرنك افريقي هي
العمله التي تضمنها فرنسا والتي تتحكم
[موسيقى]
النظام الفرنسي فهذا كل هذه العوامل
النائبه انزلاق الجيل الحالي يجيل الذي
يسعى
يعني الخروج من السياج الذي وضعته فرنسا
يعني مع رئيس ديبون
على حسب ما
الجيل السياسي الجيل الذي كان في فرنسا
يرسم السياسه الافريقيه بفرنسا هذا الجيل
ايضا عن الجيل السابق اما
استحل او تنحى عن صناعه
السياسه الفرنسيه
ويعني اتى جيل اخر يصطدم
جيل مختلف بالكامل مثلما صرت ولكن هناك
نقطه مهمه ذكرتها انقلها لضيفنا من الرباط
الدكتور تاج الدين الحسيني موضوع التحكم
في الثروات الافريقيه يعني اشار ضيفنا الى
قضيه الفرنك الافريقي هذا كل الاحتياطات
النقديه موجوده عند عند فرنسا لا يسمح
لافريقيا بعقد صفقات الا بموافقه فرنسيه
بعض الارقام تشير الى ان هذه الواردات
لفرنسا تصل الى تقريبا من من العمله
تقريبا 500 مليار دولار سنويا وفرنسا هي
التي تتحكم في الموازنات تقريبا وفي
الصفقات وغيرها ان تمسك فرنسا بكل هذه
الاشياء الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والعسكريه
والامنيه هو الذي اججز الغضب منها
فعلا هذه مساله ذات طبيعه تاريخيه اولا لا
ننسى انه عندما انتصر الحلفاء في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه قدمت وعود الى البلدان
الناميه وخاصه الافريقيه لانها سترى نوع
من الحريه والاستقلال وفعلا قامت فرنسا في
سنه 1946 بتمكين هذه البلدان في جنوب
افريقيا في جنوب الصحراء بافريقيا تمكينها
ان تكون ممثله في الجمعيه الوطنيه لكن هذا
التمثيل كان رمزيا وشكليا فقط لم تكن لها
ايه معايير للسياده عندما جاءت جمهوريه
الخامسه وجاءت باراء جديده لكنه لم يذهب
عن هذا الاتجاه بحيث لاحظنا انه عين شخصيه
معروفه لدى الفرنسيين وهي جاك فكار الذي
اصبح يطلق عليه من طرف الجميع مهندس
الاستعمار الفرنسي هذا الرجل كانت مهمته
ان يضع اتفاقيات بين فرنسا وبين هذه
البلدان الافريقيه التي اصبحت مؤهله
للاستقلال على اساس ان يكون هناك حمايه
عسكريه فرنسيه وبالمقابل هذه البلدان تضع
رهن اشاره فرنسا استغلال كل الثروات بما
فيها الماس بما فيها البترول بما فيها
الغاز بما فيها كذلك اليورانيوم علينا ان
ندرك ان اليوم فرنسا اذا انحصر عنها مثلا
اليورانيوم القادم من النيجر لن تتمكن من
تغطيه ثلث حاجيتها من زويد المفاعلات
النوويه 70% من الكهرباء في فرنسا مرتبطه
بهذا
وبالتالي هذه الوضعيه اذا نحن اخذنا بعين
الاعتبارات التطور التاريخي ثم اضفنا اليه
التراكمات خلال السنوات الاخيره نلاحظ
فعلا ان فرنسا اخطات لان نظام كما قال
ضيفكم وكما قلت قبل قليل نظام الفنك
الافريقي هذا هو مهزله على المستوى النقدي
لانه في النهايه كانت فرنسا تتوفر على كل
الاحتياطات الخاصه بهذه البلدان في
خزينتها
الان يعني وقعت مفاوضات عده مرات وقامت
فرنسا بالتنازل نسبيا 50% من الاحتياطات
النقديه توضع في الخزينه الفرنسيه ولكن في
النهايه البلدان الافريقيه تتعامل بمجرد
اوراق مطبوعه في فرنسا وبالتالي حتى
الفائض الذي تحصل عليه فرنسا كما قلتم 500
مليار دولار ربما هذا الرقم غير متفق عليه
ولكن في نهايه المطاف هذا الفائض هو الذي
يوظف منه جزء في المساعدات التي تقدمها
فرنسا لهذه البلدان الافريقيه اذا اخذنا
الاوضاع الراهنه التي تمت خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه يمكننا ان نقول بكل يقين
ان العد العكسي في العلاقات الفرنسيه
الافريقيه قد بدا بالفعل ليس فقط جنوب
الصحراء ولكن حتى في شمال افريقيا هذا
العد العكسي قد يؤدي الى قطيعه نهائيه بين
هذه البلدان وفرنسا لانه خلال السنوات
الاخيره الماضيه تبين ان هناك فشل دريع
لمبادره فرخان التي كانت من خلالها فر
تحاول ان تتقدها كوسيله متلى لتحقيق
القضاء على الارهاب هذه العمليه فشلت فشلا
ذريعا وهذا له مضاعفاته بكل تاكيد عدد
قتله فقط ما بين سنه 2012 و2022 يصل الى
11 الف من المدنيين
الافريقيين يكفي ان اشير الى مناسبه كانت
مناسبه زفاف وقتل فيها العشرات
وابتعدت فرنسا دون ان تعطي ان تضيح الى ان
فضحت الامم المتحده انما وقعه هو بسبب
الطائرات الفرنسيه وبالتالي هذا النوع من
الرفض للوجود الفرنسي اصبح يتمحور بطريقه
منهجيه لاحدث الوضعيه التي نعيشها اليوم
ربما هذا ما دعى السيد بيرتولو في باريس
دعا اكثر من 90 من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الى
في فرنسا الى توجيه رساله الى الرئيس
ماكرون لاعاده صياغه السياسه الفرنسيه
والاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه تجاه افريقيا
هل تعتقد فعلا بامكانيه التدارك في هذا
الشان
نعم
بكل تاكيد هناك احتمالات لتغيير الامور
وفرنسا على اي حال وبشكل ملح يتعين عليها
ان تفكر بهذه السياسه الافريقيه الجديده
المتعارف عليها والتي لم تنفذها بالرغم من
وعودي
الرئيس السابق الذي كان قد اقترح سلوكا
فرنسيا جديدا وبعد رئاسه ساركوزي
وايضا
لم يتمكن من تغيير سياساته بشكل كبير هناك
حاجه الى حل سريع لانه في غياب هذا الحل
ان تاثير الدومينو سوف يبدا وكل البلدان
التي كان فيها نفوذا فرنسي سوف تخرج فرنسا
من هذه البلدان لتصبح هذه البلدان بلدان
مناوئه
بلدان تتقارب من الصين وايضا روسيا روسيا
التي هي نشطه اكثر بكثير في المنطقه
الافريقيا والتي تعتبر ان فرنسا قطعت في
سياساتها التقليديه والاعتماد على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي
الروس لن يقدمون اي هدايا لفرنسا ولذلك
نحن نرى ان روسيا ناشطه للغايه في النيجر
ولربما ايضا في
البلدان الاساسيه التي كانت اساسيه من مثل
كوت ديفوار والسنغال وهي معقل فرنسا في
افريقيا والتي كانت مقربه للغايه من فرنسا
ولكن في الحقيقه لم يتم تحقيق السياسات
بشكل ايجابي والقوى المناوئه لفرنسا تعمل
لذلك هناك حاجه لاقتراح سياسه جديده بشكل
ملح وايضا هناك مشكله
يمكن ان تؤدي الى فرصه ان ازمه النيجر يجب
ان تسرع الوصول الى هذه السياسه لانه في
النهايه ما الذي يحصل ان فرنسا تهدد
بالتدخل لربما بمساعده المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا ولكن هذا
برايي يؤدي الى سياسه عكسيه اذا ما استمرت
فرنسا بهذه السياسه الاستعلائيه سوف تخاطر
تنقطع العلاقات مع كل البلدان الافريقيه
وانا اتفق مع ما قاله الضيف الكريم هناك
عدد كبير من الموارد من يورانيوم والتي هي
اساسيه بالنسبه الى فرنسا نعرف ان
كازاخستان هي الدوله المصنعه الاخرى وهي
دوره مقربه من روسيا ويمكن ان تخضع لضغوط
من موسكو كي تخفض الصادرات باتجاه فرنسا
وباتجاه الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا في فرنسا في
اللحظه الراهنه هناك مشاكل مرتبطه بقطاع
الطاقه على مستوى شركات متعدده لذلك براي
يتعين علينا ان
نتصرف بسرعه لا يجب ان ننتظر لسنه او اكثر
مماكرون يتعين عليه ان يتخذ موقفا ويقول
ما هي
العلاقه الجديده مع افريقيا وخصوصا مع
الدول التي لا تزال قريبه من فرنسا الان
في افريقيا
وايمان ماكرون ايضا كان لديه مشاكل مع
الجزائر ومع المغرب في الوقت نفسه من خلال
سياساته ونتحدث عن بلدين كنا من بين
البلدان المقربه لفرنسا في الماضي هو
بالنسبه للرئيس ماكرون ربما اطلق عديده
التصريحات التي تعبر عن رغبه في توجه جديد
مع افريقيا ولكن المشكله هنا اسال الدكتور
احمد جده في جمله المشكله هو كما قال
فرنسوا لم وهو
باحث في المعهد الفرنسي للعلاقات الدوليه
قال المشكله مع فرنسا
هو ان هناك مفارقه دائما وتباين بين
التصريحات وبين الواقع هنا هل يمكن لفرنسا
ان تعيد صياغه سياسه جديده بهذه السرعه
كما طالب اعضاء المجلس الشيوخ
نظري لا اظن ان العد التنازلي بدا وارتكبت
فرنسا حماقات سياسيه او سلوكيات سياسيه لا
رجعت فيه يعني فيه في في فيها بحيث ان
هناك عوامل اخرى تساعد
تؤدي الى هذا ان بعض الدول دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لها مستاءه من السيطره الفرنسيه
او نوع من التحكم الفرنسي في الاقتصاد
للدول افريقيا الفرانكفوريه والدول
الافريقي التي تتعامل
ايطاليا وقد صرحت رئيس الوزراء ايطاليا
لعده مرات بشده تنتقد فرنسا وتنتقد سياسه
العمله الافريقيه الى وحتى المانيا نوعا
ما كانت دائما تتحفظ واذا رجعنا الى 1994
عندما تم تخفيض العمله الفرنك سيفا
ومحاوله ربط يعني فصل الافران من الفرنك
الفرنسي وربطه باليورو كان هناك تحفظات
كبيره من عده دول اوروبيه ومن ضمنها حتى
بريطانيا يعني هناك عوامل تشجع يعني
الخروج الدول الافريقيه التي تتحكم منها
فرنسا من السيطره اما ان امكانيه يعني
وهذا او امر ان نحتاج الى زمن لان يعني
المنظومه الفكريه في فرنسا السياسيه تجاه
الدول الافريقيه ننظر حتى في الجزائر يعني
الجزائر مثلا فرنسا كانت تعتبر الجزائر
جزء من فرنسا تقول الجزائر فرنسيه فكان
يعني الخروج من الجزائر لا لم يكن الا بعد
يعني حرب معروفه وحرب الاستغلال الجزائريه
كانت حرب
فرنسا خسارات يعني وهو نفسيا فرنسا لم
تتقبل هذه الهزيمه ونفس الشيء في بالنسبه
للدول افريقيا التي لها علاقه بفرنسا خاصه
المستعمرات
فهي فرنسا لا تستطيع يعني تقبل هذه
الهزيمه يعني ظاهريا منطقيا فرنسا القاده
الفرنسيون يتكلمون عن ضروره تغيير السياسي
الفرنسيه
ولكن لا شعور الفرنسي انه ما زالوا يرفضون
فكره ان هذه الدول تكون بعيده من
التحكم الفرنسي المشكله سيد الدكتور احمد
جدا المشكله انه ليست فقط هذه الدول يعني
في رساله اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ اسال الدكتور
تاج الدين الحسيني في هذه الرساله يقولون
المشكله لم تعد فقط
مالي وبوركينا فاسو والان النيجر وانما
حتى مع دول علاقتنا معها جيده مثل كود
ديفوار او السنغال واشاروا ايضا الى شمال
افريقيا هناك المغرب والجزائر حتى تونس
لانه حتى في هذه المناطق وهذه الدول هناك
اشارات الى دور فرنسا سواء في تاييد
الحكومات او في التغلغل داخل الطبقه
السياسيه الى درجه انه البعض يصف بعض
القوى السياسيه في المجتمعات مثل المجتمع
تونس او او الجزائر او غيره بانه حزب
فرنسا وبالتالي فالمساله اعمق من مجرد
انتكاسات في افريقيا جنوب الصحراء فقط
فعلا ما اشار اليه ضيفاكم الكريمين بخصوص
مجلس الشيوخ فعلا هذا كان فيه نوع من
المفاجاه يعني كيف ينشر الشيوخ هذه
الرساله بكيفيه للجميع للراي العام ولا
تقوم الجمعيه الوطنيه باي توجه في هذا
المجال هذا سؤال مهم لان جيش المسجد
الشيوخ ومن المحافظين بالاساس يمثل الحرس
القديم قد يطرح شخص ما تساؤل هل هؤلاء
يحاولون من خلال هذه الرساله الحفاظ على
الوضع القائم كسلطه او كاستعمار قديم يمرر
نفوذه للمستقبل
الرساله عندما تقراها وقد قراتها بتمعن لا
تلاحظ هناك معاينه للاوضاع المتدهوره ولكن
ليست هناك ايه حلول تقترحها هذه الجهه من
اجل توضيح الرؤيه اعتقد ان الامر واضح
الاقوال التي يقولها الرئيس الفرنسي
بالخصوص لا تتطابق مع الافعال وهذا هو
الفرق الاساسي في السياسه الفرنسيه اليوم
وهذا ما دفع باليمين الى ان يصف الرئيس
الفرنسي في وضعيته بانه يمارس نوع من
الهوايه السياسيه وليس الكاريزما التي
تعطيه بعض الاثر الواضح على اتخاذ
القرارات لكن اليسار من جهته يعتبر ان هذه
السياسه التي يتبع الرئيس الفرنسي هي ذات
طبيعه سوقيه ولا تؤمن بمبدا النديه في
التعامل مع البلدان الاخرى ضيفكم قبل قليل
اعطى مثالا بما ذهب اليه الرئيس الافريقي
ليشعل الاضواء او لكذا هذه اشياء لا تتم
مع رؤساء الدول بطبيعه الحال الرئيس
الفرنسي حاول ان يبدل جهودا مضنيه للتقرب
من افريقيا هذا تم بالفعل يعني خلال مده
توليه الحكم منذ 2017 الان حوالي 18 زياره
للبلدان الافريقيه ولكن ماذا كانت النتيجه
نتيجه نتيجتها كانت هي هذا الوضع المتدهور
الذي تعرفه هذه العلاقات ولذلك اظن انه
اذا لم ياخذ الرئيس الفرنسي ومتخذ القرار
في فرنسا بعين الاعتبار ان المشكله لم تهم
لم تعد تهم البلدان الافريقيه في حد ذاتها
ولكن اصبح التهم بلدان الجوار الاقليمي
وان قضيه الفرانكفونيه التي كانت تؤثر
السياسه الفرنسيه من عون الاستعمار
الثقافي اصبحت متجاوزه ولم يعد لها مكان
البلدان الافريقيه جميع الان اصبحت تغير
برامجها وتطمح نحو استعمال اللغه
الانجليزيه كبديل اللغه الفرنسيه وهذا من
حقها على فرنسا ان تدرك كل ذلك وان تدرك
اكثر من هذا ان هناك اليوم تطور جديد في
العلاقه الدوليه توازنات اختلت عما كانت
عليه في الماضي هناك حضور قوي للصين
وروسيا والولايات المتحده وحتى دول صاعده
مثل تركيا مثلا وبلدان في قلب افريقيا
المغرب يعتبر الان تعتبروا فرنسا للاسف
تعتبره كمنافس ولم تعد تعتبره كشريك لماذا
لانه استطاع باذرعته الاقتصاديه المكتب
الشريف في الفوسفاط الشركات الكبرى
الابناك الوسائل البناء
كلها استطاعه بان يصل الى الاسواق
الافريقيه لانه يقوم على مبدا المصلحه
المشتركه ومبدا رابح رابح فرنسا ترفض مثل
هذا التصرف وهذا هو السبب الذي يبرر
موقفها من المغرب ومن دول اخرى في قلب
القاره ولذلك
اعضاء مجلس اشاروا الى ان فرنسا الان تخسر
الجانب العسكري اصبحت روسيا التي تعوض
فرنسا عسكريا الصين تعوضها اقتصاديا
والولايات المتحده تعوضها الدبلوماسيين
هنا نسال ضيفنا من باريس سيد برتلو اما
اذا كان بامكان فرنسا الان ان تواصل
وتنافس هؤلاء في ظل المعطيات الجديده في
افريقيا
من الواضح ان فرنسا ليس لديها هذا الثقل
العالمي بالمقارنه مع ثقل الصيني يمكن
فرنسا ان تتنافس على المستوى الاقتصادي مع
بلدان اخرى هي من حجمها واقتصاد تلك
البلدان يمكن ان يقارن بحجم الاقتصاد
الفرنسي نتحدث عن روسيا عن تركيا الهند
حتى ولو ان الهند هي ليست دوله خصمه
لفرنسا اذا مع الصين ليس هناك تكافؤ مع
بلدان اخرى يمكن ان يكون هناك تكافل ولكن
في البلدان الفرانكفونيه
الافريقيه في الاراضي
الافريقيه هناك تمدد للنفوذ الصينيه ولذلك
كما سبق واستفت لربما يتعين على فرنسا ان
تركز على بعض البلدان الاساسيه عوضا عن ان
تتبع ذاك الوهم بان باستطاعتها ان تكون
النفوذ الاقتصادي الاكبر في الاراضي
الفرنسيه السابقه هذا امر معقد بالنسبه
الى الحكومه الفرنسيه هذا عامل يجب ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار وايضا يجب ان نفهم
الثقل الاقتصادي
لفرنسا في افريقيا وهو جزء من التبادلات
ولكن اساس التبادلات الاقتصاديه بين فرنسا
والبدان الاخرى يتم في اوروبا وبعد ذلك
اسيا وايضا دول الخليج العربي وبعد ذلك
لدينا القارتين الامريكيتين وبالتالي
لدينا هذه الرؤيه المغلوطه لربما في
افريقيا انهم الدولي افريقيا
ليس لفرنسا ثقل اقتصاديه هذا خطا لان
التبادلات الاقتصاديه مع افريقيا هي جزء
بسيط من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في فرنسا
ولكن طبعا هناك حيز كبير فرنسي من السوق
وهناك ايضا انتقادات توجه الى فرنسا نتحدث
على سبيل المثال في الكود ديفوار هناك
افضليه
للشركات الفرنسيه في قطاع الاتصالات
والطرق والبنى التحتيه الى اخره بالنسبه
الى اهميه افريقيا لفرنسا هي تتعدى
المساله الاقتصاديه المهمه ولكنها ثانويه
الاهميه هي سياسيه اذا ما نجحت فرنسا بان
تحصل على هذه العضويه الكامله في مجلس
الامن منذ عام
1945 ذلك بسبب شارد غول او بفضل شاردو غول
لان كان لفرنسا
البلدان الافريقيه وهذا ما ادى الى ثقل
للدوري السياسي الفرنسي على المستوى
الدولي عشرون بلد كانوا يتبعون لفرنسا في
العام
1945 وهذا ما ادى الى النفود الفرنسي
بالاضافه الى المستعمرات في الشرق الاوسط
وفي بلدان اخرى او في اماكن اخرى ولكن
الثقل السياسي الفرنسي جزئيا موجود بفضل
العلاقه الخاصه مع افريقيا واذا ما ادارت
كل البلدان الافريقيه ظهرها لفرنسا يوم غد
الثقل السياسي لفرنسا على ساحه الدوليه
سوف يكون مشابها لاسبانيا ولا ايطاليا
نتحدث عن بلدان المهمه ولكنها ليست كفرنسا
المملكه المتحده لديها ثقل دولي بفضل
الكومنويل على سبيل المثال الا وهي
العلاقه الخاصه مع المستعمرات البريطانيه
السابقه في العالم بالنسبه الى فرنسا هناك
مواجهه واشرتم ايضا الى موضوع
الفرانكفونيه الذي يتراجع اللغه الفرنسيه
تتراجع هناك برامج في الجزائر
تحول نحو الانجليزيه وفي المغرب كذلك
اذا فرنسا بشكل عملي سوف تخسر دورها الجيو
السياسي على المستوى العالمي نحن نتحدث عن
المناطق الاقتصاديه الخالصه لفرنسا التي
هي اساسيه بفضل هذه البلدان ولكن اذا ما
ادارت هذه البلدان الافريقيه ظهرها لفرنسا
سوف تخسر فرنسا ذلك عشرون بلدا باستثناء
لربما الجزائر الجزائر كان شريكا ولكن
بشكل عام
الجير والسياسه الوطن الجيو السياسي
لفرنسا سوف يتاثر بشكل كبير وسوف تصبح
فرنسا شانها شان اسبانيا وايطاليا
وبالتالي هذا هو المعطى الاساسي وتحدي
الاساسي بالنسبه الى فرنسا باضافه الى
التحدي الاقتصادي وخصوصا في قطاع الطاقه
واليورانيوم على وجه الخصوص وايضا البترول
والغاز في بلدان افريقيه متعدده سواء
مستعمرات سابقه ام لا من مثل نيجيريا
وانغولا ولكن هل اداره الظهر هذه الدكتور
احمد جده اداره الظهر الافريقيه لفرنسا
ممكنه لانه يخشى الان ان تكون هناك فورة
معاديه لفرنسا
واعتقاد بان الحل هو في روسيا الحل هو في
الصين وقد تكون المساله مضلله بالكامل
بمعنى يهربون من المظله الفرنسيه حتى
يقعوا تحت براثا نوع اخر من من الهيمنه
ربما لا يقل سوءا
السياسيه
الفرنسيه عندما كان يتعدد عن سياسه
المكرون في افريقيا يقول ان بينما تقدم
روسيا يعني مشاريع امنيه بينما تقدم الهند
تقدم الصين مشاريع بنيه تحتيه تاتي فرنسا
لتقدم مشروع لحمايه الشذوذ اول المثليه
فهذا ملخص يعني السياسه الفرنسيه السياسه
الامر الواقع يعني سياسه الدول بروسيا او
صين هي سياسه مبنيه على المصلحه المباشره
واعرف تاريخيا لم يكن هناك علاقه تاريخيه
يعني دمويه او معقده مثل وكاله فرنسا
فرنسا كانت دوله مستعمره مستعمره وكان
سلوك المواطنين او الشعوب في هذه البلاد
يعني
السعي للتحرر بينما الصين تاتي بك شريك
هناك طبعا الحل الجزري ليس الصيد ولكن
الصين تقدم حلول دون ان تتدخل في
الحياه السياسيه او المنظومه السياسيه
داخل البلاد وكذلك روسيا فطبعا يعني القول
بان الدول الافريقيه تخرج من مظله فرنسا
هذا يعني ليس لا اطرح القضيه بهذا الشكل
انا اقول فقط ان فرنسا ان هناك ثقل او
موروث سياسي تاريخي ثقيل والصعب وان فرنسا
يعني بعد الاستقلال لمده 60 عام تقريبا
يعني الدول الافريقيه شاهد الممارسه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه لفرنسا وتريد فقط ان
تغير هذا النمط لان هذه الدول روسيا
والصين مع ان هناك لهم ايضا يعني تبعتهم
او
سلكاتب السلبيه في المناطق التي فيها هذه
البلاد ولكن بالنسبه افريقيا يعتبر تعتبر
هذه الدول كشريك لم تاتي بواجهه استعباريه
او نظره فوقيه او او يعني تغيير المنظومه
او تغيير المفاهيم او حتى القيم فهذا يعني
يختلف مع اني انا مقتنع تماما ان الحل
الجزري لافريقيا ليس فقط يعني الصين
وروسيا
اخرى ولكن عندما يكون هناك الصح هو داخل
البلاد صحوه للشعوب
يعني اخذ زمام الامور في المجال الاقتصادي
الى اخره ولكن في المرحله الحاليه
اللجوء الى روسيا او الى الصين امر ضروري
وحتمي حتى ولو لم نعرف عواقبه على المدى
المدى القريب او البعيد فحاليا الاولويه
عند الشعوب الافريقيه هو قطع الحبل السري
مع فرنسا واذا ارادت فرنسا ان ترجع الى
افريقيا يجب ان تغير اسلوب او حتى نمط
التفكير او اسلوب المعامله مع هذه الدول
ولكن هل هذا هل يمكن يعني معذره هل يمكن
هل يمكن ان يكون هذا امرا سهلا يعني نسال
الدكتور تاج الدين نسال الدكتور تجدين
حسيني فيما يتعلق تحديدا بالوجود العسكري
الفرنسي مثل ما قال باسكال بونيفاس وهو
مدير المعهد العلاقات الدوليه في في في
باريس قال اذا تمكن من انقلابيون في
النيجر من السيطره على الاوضاع فوجودنا
العسكري هناك بالتاكيد سينتهي هل تعتقد
بان صفحه الوجود العسكري الفرنسي على
الاقل طويت في انتظار ربما قوي صفحات اخرى
اقتصاديه او ثقافيه او غيرها
واكبر دليل على ذلك واننا لاحظنا في هذه
البلدان الافريقيه التي قطعت فرنسا بعد
الانقلابات سواء افريقيا الوسطى بوركينا
فاسو مالي والان النيجر لاحظنا ان هناك
حلول تدريجيا لقوات الفاغنر بدلتك القوات
الفرنسيه لا يمكن ان يتواجد الفاجرين مع
القوات الفرنسيه في نفس المكان ما اعتقد
انه سيستمر في نوع من الوجود ولون نسبي
وهو قوات ولايه المتحده التي ربما عن طريق
افريكوم وعن طريق مشاريع جديده قد تطرحها
على هذه البلدان الافريقيه ستتمكن من
الاستمرار هناك قائد انقلاب في مالي اشار
الى اشاره واضحه الى ان السياسه الفرنسيه
هي سياسه استعلائيه وفي نفس الوقت
استعماريه وابويه واحيانا يمكن ان وصفها
بانها انتقاميه ذلك نتيجه القرارات التي
تتخذ من تجميد المساعدات التي توجه هذه
البلدان من القطيعه على المستوى المالي
والتعاون الاقتصادي من سحب القوات بطريقه
مفاجئه مثلا في ماليه قيل يشكي واضح على
انه عندما سحبت قوات او انسحبت فرنسا من
برخان تم ذلك بكيفيه احاديه الجانب دون
تفاوض في اطارها الثلاثي اي لا مع الامم
المتحده ولا مع الدوله المعنيه وهذا في حد
ذاته يعتبر من الاسباب المشكله لهذا
التطور اعتقد انه اذا كانت هناك من تطورات
ينبغي ان تعرفها فرنسا اعتقد ما قاله
ضيفكم من باريس قبل قليل مهم جدا قال
فرنسا بتلك القوه التي راعي او تقوم في
وجه الصين او مثلا روسيا ولكن اعتقد ان
فرنسا لها مجالها المفضل لاتخاذ هكذا
قرارات وهو الاتحاد الاوروبي نعلم ان
اتحاد تطور بشكل قوي الى مؤسسه فوق وطنيه
والى سياسه خارجيه موحده لماذا لا تضع
فرنسا ثقلها في وسط الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليشكل مجموعه قويه للتعاون في مواجهات
القوه الكبرى ثم بالنسبه للبلدان
الافريقيه اعتقد ان المغرب كانت له تقريبا
الاجنده الممتازه في هذا المجال وهو ان
افريقيا ينبغي ان تضع ثقتها في افريقيا
وان علاقات الجوار بين هذه البلدان ينبغي
ان تقوم على التعاون المشترك وعلى
الاندماج الاقليمي وعلى رابح رابح كاسياسه
لتوجيه الاطار السياسي الفرنكوفونيه كذلك
اصبحت متجاوزه وهذا شيء تعرفه اليوم فرنسا
لغه اصبحت تختفي اليوم من الوسط الفرنسي
ورواندا التي حققت نوع من التقدم
الاقتصادي كان بفضل لجوءها الى اللغه
الانجليزيه بدل الفرنسيه وهذا النموذج كل
البلدان الافريقيه تحاول اليوم السيره فيه
ولذلك اعتقد انه حان الوقت ليفهم الجميع
سواء الفرنسيون او البلدان الافريقيه
المعنيه ان هناك وسائل جد متطوره لتغيير
الاوضاع الحاليه التي لم تعد تتطابق مع
طموحات الجيل الجديد الجيل الجديد في
افريقيا يعتبر ان فرنسا سرقت اموالها
وثرواتها وانها تطورت الى الاغناء على
حسابها درجه ان البعض قال بانه لو لم تكن
افريقيا في يد فرنسا لم تكن في الصف
السابع اقتصاديا لاصبحت في المرتبه 15
وبالتالي مثل هذه التطورات خطيره هي قطيعه
قد تؤدي الى نوع الاصطدامات علينا اليوم
ان نفهم ان المصلحه المشتركه للجميع ينبغي
ان تبحث حتى عن ابعاد بعض القوه المتفوقه
التي تشكل خطر الصين هي من الذكاء بحيث
الان تضع المشاريع الكبرى الافريقيه من
مطارات ومن ابراج ومن قناطر ومن موانئ
ولكنها في نفس الوقت تستغلهم بالنسبه
للمستقبل وقد حضر حتى بالنسبه لماكرون حذر
من ذلك وقال اتساءل كيف سيكون مستقبل
هؤلاء الى فارقه مع روسيا التي تقدم
مرتزقه في شكل الفاجنر والصين التي ستحاول
استغلالهم اقتصاديا ولن يروا هذا الا في
مستقبل يعني الافارقه حتى يتمكنوا من
تحقيق حريتهم واستقلالهم الاقتصادي عليهم
اولا وقبل كل شيء ان يبحثوا عن ذاتهم
ويؤسسوا فكره
منظمه افريقيا الغربيه هي فكره ممتازه
وتسير في تطور منهجي ويا ريت لو قبل هؤلاء
ان يكون المغرب طرفا لو قبيل المغرب
وتذكروا هذا جيدا لكانت اول خطوه ستتخذ هي
الحريه النقديه لمجموعه افريقيا الغربيه
كلها شكرا جزيلا لك من الرباط الدكتور تاج
الدين الحسيني استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه محمد الخامس شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
انجمنا الدكتور احمد جده محمد البشير
الاستاذ الجامعي وعضو البرلمان الانتقالي
في تشاد ولضيفنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
الباحث في المعهد الفرنسي للتحليل
الاستراتيجي بهذا المشاهدين الكرام تكون
قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه نلتقي باذن
الله الاسبوع المقبل وسيناريوهات جديده في
امان الله
[موسيقى]